candidats qu'il qualifie de
prestige. On les a vus. Anie
Samson et Luc Ferrandez,
bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Nadine Gelly sera président du
comité exécutif si elle sera
dans la mairie. Anie Samson,
vous en pensez quoi?
- Ces quatre belles prises pour
l'équipe de Monsieur Coderre.
Connaissant bien Monsieur
Ménard, c'est un érudit de tout
ce qui se passe au niveau
municipal et au niveau
politique. Aucun problème. Les
trois autres, ce sont des
personnes qui ne connaissent pas
la politique, mais qui ont les
capacités de pouvoir gérer. On
l'a vu avec Nadine Gelly. On l'a
vu avec Mike Parente aussi.
Chacun pourra contribuer pourra
faire avancer les choses. C'est
une belle prise.
- Luc Ferrandez, il court
sélective.
- Sentiment partagé. Ménard, je
l'apprécie beaucoup. J'espère
qu'il fera du travail de minutie
parce que j'ai pris sa suite au
Grand parquet j'ai trouvé qu'on
avait gaspillé son talent. C'est
une personne qui est très, très
minutieux. Il est tout et est
aussi un homme facilitateur avec
les gens qui l'entourent. Mike
Parente, un gars agréable et un
gars qui va faire beaucoup pour
l'aveu de Montréal. Les deux
autres, je ne sais pas comment
dire. Je suis surpris de voir
qu'il va mettre une néophyte
comme présidente. Je n'arrive
pas à comprendre.
- Jusqu'ici, vous en aviez déjà
parlé, cette capacité d'être
allé chercher quand même pas mal
de monde. Qu'est-ce que ça nous
dit sur sa campagne par rapport
à celle de Mme Plante?
- Monsieur Coderre, c'est une
personne très chaleureuse au
point de vue personnel.
Lorsqu'il a décidé qu'il allait
travailler avec toi, et devient
un ami automatiquement. C'est
une phase ami qui dure deux
heures. Après c'est ton frère.
Il t'appelle mon frère. Mais moi
quand j'étais dans
l'opposition,..
- vous êtes ton frère?
- Je n'arrivais pas à le
détester.
J'ai passé moins de deux
Il va chercher les gens et les
amène. C'est la suite, le
problème. Est-ce que peut créer
une équipe avec ces gens? Est-ce
qu'il va faire son rôle de
coaching? Est-ce qu'ils vont
juste disparaître dans la vie?
Les informer après avoir informé
les médias comme ça arrive
souvent.
- Anie Samson, une des craintes
étaient que Monsieur Coderre
donnait l'image d'un one man
show. À cette période, il donne
l'impression qu'il peut
s'entourer.
- C'est comme ça à chaque
campagne. On va voir des amis
autour de nous. Il a besoin de
103 candidats. C'est un cas
extrêmement convaincant. On peut
pas le renier. Lorsqu'il veut
quelque chose, il va les
changer. Le reste, ça va être la
suite. C'est là qu'on va passer
la véritablement changée.
- Valérie Plante, on va regarder
la fiche. On avait voulu
provoquer un clin d'oeil. La
fiche que vous voyez, elle mise
sur son sourire. Tant qu'à
parler de mon sourire, je vais
faire du judo avec ça. Qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez?
- Ça m'a fait sourire quand je
l'ai vu. Je ne suis pas sûr que
les commerçants sur la rue
Sainte-Catherine, sur la rue
Saint-Denis, sur les grandes
artères ont le sourire facile
comme elle. Je pense que c'est
un peu arrogant de faire une
publicité comme celle-là. Elle
frappe beaucoup. Est-ce que ça
va se réaliser? C'est autre
chose encore une fois. Ce sont
des belles paroles, c'est
sympathique. Quelqu'un qui ne
reste pas à Montréal, votre
tiroir. C'est bien, elle a un
sourire. Quelqu'un qui vit à
Montréal, commerçant qui peut
être pendant la pandémie a
performé son commerce,
j'aimerais bien les entendre sur
cette publicité.
- Luc?
- On se rappelle de la dernière
campagne, Coderre n'avait pas
souri. Il était amer et stressé.
Elle a voulu faire valoir ce
contraste. Je pense aussi
qu'elle a voulu séparer du rire.
Combien de fois dans les médias
sociaux et même si certains
éditorialistes ont évoqué de
Valérie Plante en disant qu'elle
nourrit en pleine face. Elle rit
facilement. Elle nourrit en
pleine face et elle rit de nous.
Elle rit de nos problèmes. Elle
voulait peut-être amenuiser le
côté rire aux éclats.
Maintenant, je ne trouve pas non
plus que c'est une bonne idée
parce que ça central et
culturel.
- On a eu un reportage vendredi
qu'on a diffusé sur la hauteur
des gratte-ciels. Monsieur
Coderre veut permettre désormais
que le gratte-ciel d'espace le
Mont-Royal. C'est une vieille
règle qui existe. De camp. Mme
Plante dit non et Mme Plante dit
qu'il faut garder ça. Qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de ça?
- Je rappelle que cette mesure a
été mise en place en 92 avec le
premier plan d'urbanisme de la
rue de Montréal. C'est havé été
mis là, ce qu'il avait raison.
Montréal se distingue par sa
montagne. Je comprends qu'on
veut identifier davantage parce
qu'on veut garder les gens en
ville. Il y a aussi une limite à
avoir allé plus loin. Je pense
que c'est une discussion au M.
Coderre a dit qu'elle
consulterait les citoyens et
qu'il prendrait acte de ce que
les citoyens vont dire pour
prendre cette décision.
J'aimerais bien voir comment va
se faire cette consultation
publique. J'aimerais bien voir
si on va écouter les citoyens
jusqu'à la fin parce que c'est
un sujet très sensible pour les
montréalais.
- Ce n'est pas juste une
question de hauteur. Quand tu
fais des immeubles en hauteur,
c'est béton car climatisé et
ascenseur. C'est un triptyque de
dépenses à moins de 700 $ de
pieds carrés. C'est en dollars
le pied carré, qui agite la?
C'est pas vrai que lorsque tu
consciente hauteur, régler le
problème des familles. Tu crées
juste plus... torontois plus
d'immeubles en hauteur qui nous
est plus de problème
d'accessibilité. La banlieue de
Toronto s'étend de plus en plus.